gotta say like Cali Cali yeah and you
have a white boy in your roster
yes I do
it's great you
know about representation sometimes yeah
and I know we have a lot of that in the
world but I just feel like it's nice to
see like women who aren't that don't
look like my Aunt claiming white boys
you know yeah I know a lot of people are
like dang why did she say that I'm like
cause y'all need y'all moments we need a
moment you gave it to us so I appreciate
that thank you do you literally have a
white guy on your roster at all or have
you ever been with a white dude no I
don't have a white boy on my roster
right now but um when I was in high
school I this was the only way I thought
was super cute he was so handsome but I
don't know you never like she never even
gave us a chance just it's just great
for the lyrics I mean yeah I'm
manifesting okay okay yeah yeah they say
once you go white you'll be all right
you know what I mean I never heard that
in my
bed once you go by Ubi that's so funny